zunächst herzlich willkommen auch hier
beim bild tv ein neues format meine
frage habe ich ihnen ja schon am samstag
gestellt aber ich glaube die erwachten
auch viele bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland eine antwort würden sie ein
bündnis mit den linken eingehen ja oder
nein die antwort ist gar nicht so schwer
wie er sagen wir machen das nicht ich
sage klipp und klar auch mit der afg
wollen wir nichts zu tun haben die haben
zu verschwinden aber für die sicherheit
in deutschland wäre es wichtig dass sie
diese frage beantworten eine partei die
die bundeswehr ablehnt die vieles
ablehnt was sie auch ablehnen mit denen
darf man nicht koalieren also klipp und
klar ja oder nein
ich finde es geht darum dass die wille
und wille ein mandat vergeben dann kann
man sehen was geht es wird ja im
augenblick über eine ganz andere
konstellation des spektrums ist es jetzt
will ich ganz deshalb will ich eine ganz
klare antwort geben ich werde nur eine
regierung bilden bei der alle parteien
einverstanden sind also klar sind dass
wir die transatlantische partnerschaft
pflegen müssen dass wir die
verpflichtungen die wir mit der nato
gemeinsam einzugehen haben auch eingehen
eine regierung bilden die sich klar
bekennen zu einer starken souveränen
europäischen eine regierung bilden die
solide mit dem geld wirtschaft dafür
sorgt dass die ok das ist das ist dass
qualität und das ist doch klar das
erklären die koalitionsgespräche
sicherheit auch okay ganz nimmt und
durch das heißt sie beantworten die
frage von armin laschet nicht ich
beantworte sie so wie ich sie gerade
beantwortet habe und nicht die
möglichkeiten die wir haben werden sich
aus dem wahlergebnis ergeben und ich
sage ja noch es wird der blick mehr über
was sie sind als spekuliert sie sind
doch nie es stimmt sie sind noch nie
bisher hervorgetreten hat gesagt sie
sind noch nie bisher hervorgetreten als
ein besonderer freund der linkspartei
ich frage mich wer wer oder was sie
daran hindert einfach die armin laschet
frage klar zu beantworten und sagt nee
ich will mit denen nicht collini es wird
jetzt erst mal gewählt und es sind zu
viele dabei die vision mittelalterlicher
first wie zinnsoldaten das ist ein trick
von ihnen sie sammeln nämlich auf beiden
seiten schön die stimmen ein
möglicherweise würde es dem wähler aber
eben das hat rein ja auch angedeutet dem
würde es eben gefallen der will das von
ihnen wissen der ami laschet will von
ihnen wissen aus ganz anderen motiven
aber der wähler will's wissen mit wem
sie koalieren sonst ist es nämlich am
ende ein trick von ihnen der landet ganz
anders bei ganz anderen politischen
zielen als der die absicht hat wenn der
ihnen die stimme gibt ich glaube wer
mich wählt oder die der npd die stimme
gibt der kriegt auch das was er bestellt
gewissermaßen und das bedeutet ja auch
dass man über die fragen ändert sich
sprich die wir eben gerade diskutiert
haben aber das ist doch das ist nicht so
abzutun mit irgendwelchen
koalitionsgespräch der wale und so
weiter sondern ist es doch die frage ist
ob die ganz unter nato bekennen ist
überhaupt keine nebligen haargenau und
deswegen könnte man ja ganz klar sagen
linkspartei kommt überhaupt nicht in die
tüte ich sehe keine seen mit der raute
und schließen die links liegen
wahrscheinlich aus kann nicht anders
sein als dass jede regierung in
deutschland ihre verpflichtung in der
nato akzeptiert und zwar aus vollem
herzen nochmal sie machen die raute sie
stellen sich in die tradition von frau
merkel frau merkel schließt auf jeden
fall eine koalition mit der linkspartei
aus und sie schließen sie eben nicht aus
das ist ein trick es ist gar kein trick
ist es demokratie und die demokratie
besteht darin dass man mit seinem votum
klar machen kann was man möchte und ich
finde dass einige versuchen ja auch
schon wenn sie über das diskutieren was
gegenwärtig mehr geredet wird als gerade
in unserer weiter gespräch nämlich wie
das klappen könnte mit einer koalition
liberalen koalition mit grünen zusammen
reden die schon mit mir über details und
wie ich koalitionsverhandlungen führen
würde kann ich nur zu sagen kann man
jetzt auch nicht machen das muss mir das
stimmt sich aus dem votum ergeben das
stimmt allerdings halte ich das für eine
wesentlich einfachere fragen eine
koalition mit der linken auszuschließen
aus den von ihnen genannten gründen ist
ein ganz klares argument ich habe ja
viele argumente für die richtige
regierung das richtige aber offenbar
auch argumente es im moment nicht
auszuschließen das müssen wir nach wie
vor festhalten die frage wird inhalt
immer wieder gestellt und die einhaltung
der armenische kriegt die antworten auch
nicht sagt am ende nochmal ja oder nein
ist halt so einfach ist es ja auch
kriegt die anforderung das ist mir so
dass einige sich davor fürchten das ist
ein starkes votum gibt und eine für die
spd ich kanzler werden kann und eine
regierung die vielleicht ganz anders ist
als sie jetzt gerade
diskutieren das schließen sie nicht aus
das müssen wir heute abend leider auch
noch mal festhalten
[Musik]